[Music]
the movement of carrying forward the
form of itself knowledge is the labor
which it accomplishes as actual history
the religious community so far as it is
at first the substance of absolute
spirit is the uncultivated Consciousness
whose existence is all the harsher and
more barbarous the deeper its inner
spirit is and the deeper its spirit is
the harder the task that its torp itself
has with its Essence with the alien
content of its consciousness
not until Consciousness has given up
hope of overcoming that alienation in an
external that is alien mannered as a
turn to itself because the overcoming of
that alienation is the return into
self-consciousness
not until then does it turn to its own
present world and Discover it as its
property thus taking the first step
towards coming down out of the
intellectual world or rather towards
quickening the abstract element of that
world with the actual self
through observation it finds on the one
hand existence in the shape of thought
and comprehends it and conversely in its
thinking it comprehends existence when
to begin with it is thus expressed the
immediate Unity of thought and being
the unity of abstract Essence in the
self abstractly and when it is expressed
the Primal light in a purer form that is
as Unity of extension and being for
extension is the simple Unity which more
nearly resembles pure thought than light
does and in doing so is revived and
thought the substance of the Orient
Spirit at once recoils in horror from
the abstract Unity from this selfless
substantiality and against it affirms
individuality
but only after it is externalized this
individuality in the sphere of culture
thereby giving it an existence and
establishing it throughout the whole of
existence only after Spirit has arrived
at the thought of utility and it's in
its absolute freedom is grasped
existence as its will only then does it
turn the thought of its inmost depths
outward and enunciate Essence as I
equals I
but this I equals I is the movement
which reflects itself into itself for
since this identity being absolute
negativity is absolute difference the
self-identity of the eye stands over
against this pure difference which as
pure and at the same time objective to
the self-knowing self has to be
expressed as time so that just as
previously Essence was declared to be
the unity of thought and extension it
would now have to be grasped as the
unity of thought and time
but the LA the difference left to itself
UNR resting and un halting time
collapses rather within itself
it is the objective Repose of extension
while extension is pure identity with
itself the i in other words
the eye is not merely the self but the
identity of the self with itself but
this identity is complete and immediate
otherness immediate Oneness with self or
this subject is just as much substance
substance just by itself would be
intuition devoid of content
or the intuition of a Content which as
determinant would be only accidental and
with lack necessity substance would pass
for the absolute only insofar as it was
thought or intuited as absolute unity
and all content would as regards its
diversity have to fall outside of it
into reflection and reflection does not
pertain to substance because substance
would not be subject would not be
grasped as reflecting on itself and
reflecting itself into itself would not
be grasped as spirit
if a Content were to be spoken of any
way it would on the one hand only be
spoken of in order to cast it into the
empty abyss of the absolute and on the
other it would be a Content picked up in
external fashion from sense perception
knowledge would seem to have come by
things by what is different from itself
and by the difference of a variety of
things
without comprehending how and whence
they came
paragraph
803 is one of the longer paragraphs in
hegel's phenomenology there's a lot
going on in there and I thought you know
maybe I should break it into two
commentary videos as I did earlier on
for a paragraph that spanned two pages
of the Miller translation but I decided
we'll see if we can pack it all into one
single commentary and there is a lot to
pack in so this might be a longer
discussion than usual and I want to
begin at the start with this this
interesting phrase the movement the beve
going right of carrying forward of you
know bringing things to the end the form
of its self-knowledge so knowledge of
what the self is and we're going to see
this discussed quite a bit in terms of
the I equals I which sounds you know
almost tautological empty as we're going
to see haga will talk about an abyss in
just a bit but it turns out to be quite
robust now there's a trap that we can
fall into which we'll talk about in a
bit so self-knowledge remember that for
Hegel
in general self-knowledge is not just a
kind of Naval gazing or thought thinking
itself if we want to use the formulation
from Aristotle's metaphysics in its bare
sense
self-knowledge is also associated with
action with Choice with as we're going
to see in just a moment an engagement
with the world of actuality and here
Hegel is going to use a term that he
hasn't for quite a while
he's going to talk about
carrying this forward is the labor the
arbites right which it accomplishes
as what
so he uses this term actual history
vehicle
so is history right and vehicle means
actual real something where we've done
something and we're going to see you
know discussion about individuality
coming up here as well and we're always
we could say
immersed whether we realize it or not in
actual history we often don't realize
it's a little bit of a pun there right
since to become real is part of what
vehicle kite is about so this is where
we're going now you notice he's not
going to use this term history in the
rest of this paragraph you might say
well why why not well he is going to
talk about time right
um and he is going to talk about certain
developments that have taken place
within in the phenomenology and the
first place he's going to start is with
the religious community the gamina that
we encountered back in the religion
section
I think with these remarks about the
religious community here we have to
understand it in a double way so on the
one hand where does religion come up
thematically within hagel's
phenomenology it's the second to last
section the one right before this
absolute knowing section
on the other hand Hegel is not
you know deluded about the fact that
religion is there in as far as we can go
back in history
so it's part of the Matrix in which
human beings develop and and we can keep
in mind both of these senses now
remember the religion section was itself
tracing out the development of religious
Consciousness self-consciousness you
know connected together culminating in
what Hegel calls the you know the uh
ultimate form of religion which is
Christianity and of course for hegel's
not you know Eastern Orthodoxy or
Catholicism it's going to be Protestant
Christianity he doesn't talk about that
so much in this work but in you know for
example the uh
lectures on the philosophy of history or
the lectures on the philosophy of
religion he's pretty clear about that so
anyway religious community right so he
says the religious community
so far as it is at first the substance
that's a term that he's using throughout
here quite a bit the substance of
absolute spirit so what it is that
absolute spirit is we could say in
itself right
um the religious community is that from
the beginning but that this is in a
somewhat developed state or we remember
that the religious community is
organizing itself and understanding
itself through for stellen not through
but great for concept or as Miller
translates it notion so the religious
community
is the uncultivated
Consciousness whose existence is all the
harsher and more barbarous the deeper
its inner spirit is and the deeper its
spirit is the harder the task that it's
torped now notice this term self right
so we've got this contrast happening
here between substance and self the
harder the task the labor that its torp
itself has with its Essence with the
alien content of its Consciousness so
what is Hegel talking about there
well
in religion and not just in the religion
section
but in the places where religion has
come up within the phenomenology earlier
for example in the self-consciousness
section where the culmination of it was
the unhappy Consciousness the largest
section in that that portion of the work
and then later on in the spirit section
where we have several different forms of
religion coming up you know
that of the community and the family
right this contrast that is summarized
perhaps in the Antigone later on with
faith and its struggle with
Enlightenment and we can go on and on
and on right
so
there's an alienation a frenzine that is
taking place
and you know it's it's interesting he
also talks about an oyster Hong right
externalization
and there is within Spirit within the
self-consciousness kind of a split right
if we think back to the unhappy
Consciousness totally about this
alienation that's going on and he says
um you know why is this because in
religion
the spirit is located deeper and deeper
and deeper you got to do work to bring
it out
so I mean this is a part of what is
attractive about religion I think for a
lot of people I'll just give you one
funny example from my own past which is
very specific I used to go to the Newman
Center which is a place where Catholic
students can go at secular universities
and I'd encounter these people who are
all about the Latin mass and I knew that
none of these people actually knew Latin
and they didn't even have missiles to
follow along with it like my you know
old ancestors did you know my my family
is uh francophone as well as anglophone
so I've got like an old missile that my
great-grandmother had where it's the
mass and Latin and then you know French
so you can figure out what the hell is
actually being said and there were many
of these and I talk with these people
and I say they'd be like oh I went to a
Latin Mass it was so amazing so great so
beautiful so you know Transcendent and
I'd be like
yep you don't actually know Latin so you
don't know what the hell's that being
said and they'd say exactly that's what
makes it feel so so spiritual and I'd be
like that's the opposite of what's
supposed to be going on from a hegelian
perspective right uh that would be
complete nonsense this is not even
mysticism it's just silliness
um but you gotta dig you got to dig you
gotta dig in in religion to figure out
where spirit is is actually located so
he says not until Consciousness has
given up hope of overcoming of aufhaven
right that alienation now what does it
give up it's hope it's
not of overcoming the alienation totally
but of the modality of overcoming that
alienation there's a right way in this
case to overcome alienation and there's
a less productive perhaps even
counterproductive way of doing so that
just kicks the alienation can down the
road if you know that expression of
kicking the can down the road relocating
it further uh into the process so he
talks about uh giving up hope of
overcoming that alienation in an
external that is alien Manner and
external
um or friend uh you know
not what you need overcoming alienation
is not going to be done by adding more
alienation
then he says um
it turns to itself
because
the overcoming of that alienation the
actual alphabel
is a return
to self-consciousness
and so we could say okay no longer just
Consciousness self-consciousness great
we've done this hegelian transition so
many times the whole religion section
was supposed to be about the you know
reconciliation of Consciousness and
self-consciousness cool
well self-consciousness exists with a
world not just all by itself
not just as necessarily involved with
other self-consciousnesses as we saw
back in the self-consciousness section
as we saw throughout the rest of the
phenomenology but also with a world and
that's a world that includes other
people and that's a world that has a
history as we're going to see right an
actual world isn't just a bunch of stuff
all thrown together it coheres and it
changes over time so we're going to come
to that in just just a moment so
um
not until then does it turn to its own
present world
right and Discover it as its property
it's eigen to him oh this is very
interesting isn't it to see Hegel using
this term property
the world becomes
its own
you know what belongs to the
self-consciousness I mean can the world
really belong to a self-consciousness
strictly speaking no because the world
is owned in parts and Parcels by all
sorts of people if we're thinking about
legal property right I mean at one time
the world had a lot of blank spots where
somebody could come along and plonk a
house hold down and say this is my
property now I mean now just about
everything is is owned if not by
individuals but by governments but
hegel's not just talking about legal
ownership here he's talking about uh
appropriating the world as a
self-consciousness I mean in this sense
so take a museum for example it is owned
by you know probably the museum
organization or perhaps the city that
the museum is in
but we all own it at least in part every
time that we go in and participate in
the uh
observation the term we're going to use
in just a moment of the various matters
that are on display curated for us right
this is why people can tick us off we
can be like oh I want to have a nice uh
quiet picnic at the park and these
people are playing music over here and
Grilling and I don't like the smell of
their their food that they're cooking
well I mean it's shared property right
so coming back to Hagel after those
examples he says
um not until then
oh well let's talk about this so the
overcoming of that alienation is the
return into self-consciousness not until
then does it turn to its own present
world and discover its property thus
taking the first step of coming down out
of the now notice what he says
intellectual World intellectual wealth
or rather towards quickening the
abstract elements of that world with the
actual self the vehicle
the self that you know has a body a
location in in time is moving through
time has a certain amount of money in
their bank account wears certain clothes
all of these things that differentiate
and individuate us
so how does this take place well he
talks about several different things
that are actually happening and the
reason in the spirit section so
observation he says through observation
it finds on the one hand existence the
design in the shape of thought and
comprehensive and conversely in its
thinking and comprehends existence so
this is talking about what happened in
the very first part of the reason
section which is actually quite long
there's a lot of stuff going on in there
going all the way from you know sort of
the science of the time which Eagles
kind of
you know I mean it's not stuff that we
necessarily buy into now through
um uh all the way to phrenology and uh
physiognomy right
um and and you know trying to observe
living things trying to make sense of
them and we're the ones who do that we
are the self-consciousnesses we are the
spirits that that do that and so what is
this going to lead us to
um
this is going to lead us to a connection
or as we're going to say the immediate
Unity einheit
of thought
and being
as he's going to call it
the unity of abstract Essence and the
self and it expresses this abstractly
now he's coming back to the religion
section the very first thing that we
looked at was natural religion right and
no we didn't begin
um just with light you know there's all
different possibilities for the natural
religion section but the purest of them
is the religion of Light which Hegel you
know mistakenly presents as if it's our
astronisms or asterianism historically
much more complex than that but you know
you can see what he's saying here so
when it is expressed the Primal light in
a pure form
and what is that going to be
a Unity of extension
and being right
um and
so what is that uh be in a being
understood the being that we encounter
understood through through measure
through extension should point out that
for Hegel
um anything that you can measure and
quantify is at kind of a lower level
than things that are more reflexively
intense like qualities right so
um saying that something is is extension
is is not you know making it very
valuable right so he says extension is a
simple Unity which more nearly resembles
pure thought then light does and in
doing this it is revived in thought the
substance of the the East right where
the uh
well the sun begins right
and then he says interestingly Spirit at
once recoils in horror from the abstract
Unity
there's something about pure
abstractions that do entice people in
and they're like oh this is awesome but
then when we look at them we're like uh
no no no that is not enough for me
that's
lacking determinate meaning I don't know
how to apply this in my actual life it
sounds really awesome but what the hell
am I this complicated self-conscious
what the hell am I supposed to do with
this
in an actual world as an actual self
so he says what is it recoiling and
horror from selfless
substantiality and against it what does
it do it affirms individuality
right
eisenheit
being an actual person this is tied in
with vehicle with actuality
so what is that like
so now we get to culture individuality
and culture coming in the spirit section
late in the spirit section actually so
he says only after it's externalized
this individuality in the sphere of
culture thereby giving it an existence a
dazine and establishing it throughout
the whole of existence only after
spirits
how do we determinately express this has
arrived at the thoughts of utility
um
this is something that Hagel discusses
at that considerable length in the
spirit section and he is trying to
capture the movement of thought within
the intellectual world and the actual
world of the time leading up to him
I mean keep in mind that if we want to
talk about utility
utilitarianism as an actual philosophy
organized by and articulated as such by
Jeremy Bentham is not that distant from
Hegel
you know Jeremy Bentham is writing in
the late uh 18th and early 19th century
at the time that Hegel himself is on the
scene but Bentham is putting together
modes of thinking that have been kicked
around for you know 200 years in very
active ways in the various
enlightenments uh or auf Clarence that
have taken place you know David Hume
talks about utility quite a lot
Shaftsbury uh you know all these French
encyclopediasts that are dominating the
18th century that hegel's read well
they're all talking about utility and
this is a very important way of
changing the the world that we're we're
in
so individuality and uh utility right
culture and then he goes on and talks
about only after Spirit has arrived at
the thought of utility and in its
absolute freedom
so this is getting towards freedom and
the terror that we're going to find
which then transitions us into other
other discussions
only after that
um does it turn to the thought of its in
most does it turn the thought of its
inmost steps outward and enunciate
Essence as I equals I
um and then he goes on and says but this
I equals I is the movement which
reflects itself into itself so now we're
going to talk a little bit about what
does
if hegel's used this formula a lot I
equals I right
you know equals is glyc is equivalent to
uh itself
um
should this be understood as a mere like
repetition
like hand is hand right as a tautology
well that would be abstract and that is
a possibility
but we're going to see that that's not
all that's going on here can't be all
that's going on that would be a trap
that would lead us off of the path and
not get us to the end of absolute
knowing that would just lead us into
another
spiral into a cul-de-sac that we we wind
up
finishing our quest in without being
satisfied
so what does it really mean
hegel's going to tell us in a couple
different points here's the first one
this I equals I is the movement which
reflects itself into itself
sense this identity being absolute
negativity is absolute difference
so not as notice identity absolute
negativity absolute difference the
self-identity
of the eye Subs glycate right and so
identity here glyphide can also mean
equivalence can also mean you know
corresponding to
um I think we should understand it in a
more robust manner as I've you know
mentioned in earlier uh commentaries
so it stands against this pure
difference right
um
the self-identity of the eye stands over
against this pure difference which as
pure and at the same time objective
to the self knowing self has to be
expressed now we get to something else
time
so just as previously Essence was
declared to be the unity of thought and
extension
oh was it it was the unity of extension
and being and now Hegel says well it was
the unity of thought and extension and
we could say well I you know by the
transitive property or something since
thought and being are in a Unity then if
being an extensioner in unity then
thought and extension must also be in
that Unity right okay that's that's fine
but now we have a transition to thought
and time
that's different
you could think of time as merely
another kind of extension which is what
we do when we're you know mathematically
modeling thing or just talking about
time as being the fourth dimension right
but Hegel thinks that time is uh
different than that
he says
um
the difference left to itself unresting
and unhalting time
it collapses into itself
within itself
it is the objective Repose of extension
while extension is pure identity with
itself the eye
now that is something
kind of bizarre to say right when we
think of extension
so this is a technical term we're
thinking about space and things that are
in space
are they the eye
well I mean you and I exist in space
right this body that I however we want
to understand it I'm working through
carry around with my myself and my soul
is me whatever we make of my body that's
extension
very complicated extension too
but what about external things like you
know this chalkboard that I've written
all these nice diagrams on and notes
does that have a self
it's not conscious
right
so
how is that supposed to be an I an I
that equals I
uh well it's it's not it's an eye it's a
it's a thing existing for this eye me
and the eye that is you so let's go on
with this right he says the I the ich
which is equal to itself
is not merely the self
but
the identity the glyph height once again
right
of the self with itself of the zebst MIT
uh
formula that he's going to use and again
just in a moment
and he says this identity is complete
for culmina okay so complete think of
not in sense of uh like taking off a
bunch of boxes or couldn't be any better
but rather at the end of a process of
development of coming to fruition right
so it's complete and unmediated on metal
bar one is einheit
with the self now Miller's translation
here just a little bit lacking in nuance
it's not I mean technically speaking yes
it is complete and unmediated unity with
the self right the the self that is the
eye but he's actually saying
unmediated Oneness with its own self
meet Zeke zelbs and this means that the
unity
it's not simple Unity right it may be
unmediated at this stage
although as we know nothing has ever
truly unmediated for Hegel but there's
actually a
a duality at least within the self
so
we go on
and he's going to unpack this a bit more
what is what is a way of understanding
this identity a complete and an
immediate Oneness with the self
this subject is just as much substance
okay so we got self Spirit substance and
subject the four asses that Hegel often
plays around with
so the self
um engages with substance is a substance
but it can't just be a substance because
a substance is something it's not just
that a substance is inert because many
substances are quite active and do
things it's that a substance that is
lacking
subjectivity
is just a substance and the self can't
be that kind of substance can it nor
can the absolute spirit that was grasped
originally through religion be something
that's merely substance it also has to
be subject
so what does he say here substance just
by itself would be intuition
devoid of content or the intuition of a
Content which as determinate would be
only accidental and Theory actually uses
a cognitive term accidental uh and would
lack necessity note vending Heights it
would just be contingent it would just
show up and wouldn't have any meaning
outside of itself it might be something
that we want to eat or appreciate but it
wouldn't have any greater connection or
meaning
substance so substance
would be just abstract in this case
and he says substance would pass through
the absolute
only insofar as it was thought or
intuited as absolute Unity
so it would include everything right
and all content would as regards its
diversity have to fall outside of it in
reflection reflection which is what
self-consciousness does so if there's
some substance and that's the be-all and
end-all and I'm not it and it doesn't
really do much of anything and I'm the
one thinking about it engaging in
reflection there's something let's say
substantial that's not in that substance
which means that it's not really what it
pretends to be the you know substance of
absolute knowing however we want to put
it we better be involved in it somehow
it better Encompass us
and in a way that allows us to you know
maintain ourselves as individual
self-consciousness I mean Hegel doesn't
think that the end of the process is all
of us in some mystical fusion with some
Primal unity and then we just like hang
out and you know take it in man he's not
a hippie or you know some Zen bomber or
something like that I mean real Zen is
not like the portrayal that we see in
popular culture anyway it's actually
kind of complicated
um hegel's not for that
the substance had better not be the end
of the story and that reflection like he
says reflection does not pertain to
substance why
because substance would not be subject
what is reflection it's
you know thinking about oneself it's
thinking about what you're related to
it's it's taking a higher stand in your
understanding your cognition your
whatever we're going to talk about
you're thinking
so he says uh substance would not be
subject would not be grasped as
reflecting on itself and reflecting
itself into itself would not be grasped
as Spirits Spirit when it's really
spirit and not just sort of its dead
bones the stuff that happened along the
way left there behind us off right
spirit is reflection it involves
reflection it takes the self and it
takes the substance and it brings them
together in some way that
isn't totally unmediated either
so hey goal goes on
and he says
um
if a Content were to be spoken of anyway
it would
uh on the one hand only be spoken of in
order to cast it into the empty abyss of
the absolute
Hegel doesn't want the uh absolute to be
understood as an empty Abyss as
something that's beyond communication
about it Beyond conceptualization of it
right that's a false absolute and then
he says on the other would be a Content
picked up in external fashion from sense
perception just grasping something
contingent within the world
neither of these are good options from a
hegelian perspective
so he says knowledge would seem to have
come by things by what is different from
itself right an alienation that takes
place uh and by the difference of a
variety of things without comprehending
how and whence they came so this is
charting out for us a don't go down this
path
we need to do something else and this is
what's going to happen in the few
paragraphs that we still have left to
come explaining how all of this comes
together and we should remind ourselves
as we finish this up Hegel thinks that
this actually does happen through a
historical process in which spirit
unfolds itself develops a very
complicated ways that we then ourselves
can go back as a phenomenologists and as
people involved in these processes and
formed by these processes yourself and
he thinks that he's charted out the
significant portions of this development
here in the phenomenology of spirit I I
did say that that was the last thing but
I will say one other further thing as
well we shouldn't take
what is being laid out for us in the
phenomenology of spirit as the absolute
final word from Hegel on this because he
you know he did write other books he
goes on and provides all these lectures
to his students which add to the picture
so if we're thinking about the
historical process lectures on the
philosophy of History lectures on the
history of philosophy both incredibly
important right and we learn some things
about this process on on the way
but this is enough for right now so
we've gotten through this massive
paragraph now we can start making some
more forward progress to the absolute
knowing final end point